this kind of program would best benefit
those people who wants a garden versus
actually going into the community and
trying to persuade people to garden
because that takes a different approach
and it goes beyond food security it goes
beyond food as a facilitator the
community's needs always come first and
it's hard to watch that because we are
also in an educational system where
there are sort of experts and people who
are not experts so as experts we come in
thinking oh this is what they need but
that's what it's failed for so many
years coming in with that mindset so
coming in with letting the community
decide what they want in the day is the
most important part partnerships are
very very community specific so for
example if you're working with like a
Senior Living Center it's not a better
set of the food that grown it's about
the type of spices it reminds them of
home it reminds them of a time of their
lives and it's in a lot of seniors aging
can bring about issues of isolation
loneliness so anything that can remind
them of home it's something that they
want and what we've seen in Downton is
become and some of the Senior Living
Centers is that more the gardens are
herb based and that's an example of
being community specific and
understanding community knowledge
because you're going into a population
that has knowledge of the old days and
they want to remember the old days and
under the old days so the partnerships
also about being community specific it
encourages community involvement and
participation in all levels but then it
also empowers communities to commit to
long term change it seems because the
bean plant grows perfectly around the
corner doesn't suffocate the corn at all
actually they go together thinking about
see December facilitation it's a
partnership but it's not defined based
on what we think a partnership is to be
a lot of times we think it's a 50/50
thing when working with communities is
never 5050 it could be eight its winning
it could be twenty forty I mean it it
might mean it might not even be a
hundred percent and we have to rid
ourselves on the idea
what we think a partnership is and
rethink the idea of a partnership and
that's what cedar Supper is all about
when it comes to community development
you